une élection législative partielle dans
la 12e circonscription des yvelines la
conséquence directe de la nomination de
nadia ministre délégué chargé de la
ville pour rejoindre le gouvernement
elle a décidé de démissionner de son
mandat à l'assemblée nationale
objectif éviter que son suppléant moussa
waroux ce lui succède au parlement en
août 2019 il a été mise en examen dans
le cadre d'une affaire de trafic de
stupéfiants
sur son compte twitter le principal
intéressé assure que la démission a été
prise d'un commun accord avec nadia et
dans un délai de trois mois les
électeurs de la 11e circonscription vont
être appelés aux urnes pour élire leurs
députés
conseiller municipal d'opposition de
trappes othman nas roues a été le
premier à annoncer sa candidature sur
les réseaux sociaux
naturellement cette élection législative
partielle elle se fait dans la suite du
combat que je mets la trappe qui l'a vu
grandir de la circonscription il y en
ad'autres naturellement et pour toutes
celles et sept villes de la
circonscription moi je souhaite
représenter dignement les habitants
d'aceh
pour ce qui est de faire l'assemblée
nationale ont porté d'abord je lui dis
un combat pour les valeurs de la
république
je me suis toujours positionné comme un
candidat de la droite et du centre est
donc naturellement je suis ouvert mais
je suis un élu aussi et de la droite
républicaine
je ne vais jamais renier et ce sont
aujourd'hui ces valeurs là que je
souhaite porter
de son côté le nouveau maire de trappes
à lire ab souhaite se consacrer à sa
commune en revanche il a son idée pour
représenter la gauche lors de ce
prochain scrutin
moi personnellement je vous le dis je ne
le cache pas je souhaite que benoît
hamon reviennent dans le jeu politique
je souhaite qu'il soit pourquoi pas
député de la 11e circonscription
malheureusement ça ne dépend pas que de
moi mais je cherchais je tâcherai de le
convaincre et j'espère que les
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
nous donneront l'occasion de re voir
benoît hamon en première ligne
je souhaite que nadia et viennent
remettre son titre en jeu
si elle gagne les élections législatives
qui aura lieu d'ici trois mois elle
pourra comme ministre à prendre ses
responsabilités et son suppléant ira
siéger à l'assemblée nationale pour le
moment la république en marche n'a pas
pris de décision concernant cette
élection la réflexion est en cours
les sont pour l'instant les candidats
qui vont se manifester
je ne sais pas encore les candidats qui
vont se positionner tout à l'heure j'ai
eus par sms de quelqu'un que je connais
qui est marcheurs de la première heure
qui souhaitent avoir un échange avec moi
parce qu'il souhaite se positionner
pour rappel lors du second tour des
élections législatives de 2010 est dans
la 11e circonscription
nadia et l'avait emporté avec 52 96% des
suffrages devant le candidat les
républicains jean michel fourgous